what a historic day so historic that
this just can't wait
Trump sat down with North Korean
dictator Kim Jong hoon to take the first
step towards peace as Churchill famously
said the first step towards peace is a
thirsty photo-op look at that backdrop
iconic a wall of American and North
Korean flag side by side a beautiful
blur of red white and blue
you're gonna hardly tell them apart but
in this picture equals partners the
beginning of a beautiful friendship
look at them legitimizing each other on
the world stage like Oprah did with
books Trump gets it
reality is blurry Kim isn't a monster
he's a talent Kim jong-un has killed
family members has starved his own
people why are you so comfortable
calling him very talented well he is
very talented at anybody that takes over
at 26 years of age and is able to run it
and run it tough see one man's crimes
against humanity is another man's fiery
management style that's not Trump wants
to run our country tough with a whole
new set of tough talented friends just
think of the potential photo ops Darth
Vader he took over pretty young two
sharks sure Trump hates them but that's
just because of their rows of super
sharp talons the asteroid from
Armageddon it threatened earth took up
earth Willis and set off the chain of
events that led to Ben Affleck's
majestic back tattoo that's frightening
true talent so get on board liberals
this is what peace looks like a captured
frozen moment with no regard for
historical context
the fight continues good you hit down
here with a real truth lies you wanna
help me defeat the globalists and stay
on the inside click and subscribe and
help me defeat them because following me
on my youtube channel makes you a leader
it tracks trust me